die kette ja mittlerweile meine freundin
lara ich habe ein oder zwei videos mit
ihr gedreht ihr habt vielleicht auch
gemerkt dass sie nie mit mir gekocht hat
das liegt daran dass sie eigentlich nie
kocht meine freundin hat wirklich nicht
allzu viel übrig fürs kochen was aber
auch gar nicht so schlimm ist ich dachte
mir ich gebe aber einen kleinen anreiz
um das zu ändern und ich koche gegen
sierre geht einkaufen stellt uns einen
wahren kopf zusammen und sagt uns
welches gericht wir für ihn kochen
sollen wir sehen nichts von der
zubereitung des jeweils anderen und am
ende ist es ihr gericht gegen meinen
gericht klingt erstmal um färber ich bin
mir sehr sicher dass lara sich große
mühe geben wird und ich sollte das nicht
auf die leichte schulter nehmen deshalb
wenn ich mir eine kleine stärkung und
ihr könnt es auch mit dem kot 5 max 5 es
gibt nämlich verschiedenste leckereien
ihr habt ihr schon den letzten videos
gesehen es gibt eine große vielfalt von
produkten danke fürs unterstützen eines
kanals legen wir los mit dem video
[Musik]
augen zu
[Gelächter]
nadal ist aufgeregt
32 als
graf ist das dann sitze ich
habe mir ein gericht gewünscht welches
ich betriebs als langsame die wälder
konkubine alla milanese
also übersetzt mit gemüse lasagne und
dazu und ihr habt genau eine stunde zeit
der karte starteten 32
ich denke mal ein zwei sachen wer dich
nicht benutzen ich habe noch nie so was
gemacht noch nie ich muss einen kurzen
blick drauf werfen
anfängt ich glaube aber dass gleich
mache ich zum schluss dass du dir schon
einmal recht ja also ich bereit dann
auch schon schöne tomatensoße und werdet
dann das ganze einfach schön saison
bastelt auch wirklich ein richtiges eric
dylla saniert dazu sonst
deutet auf jeden fall reichen also muss
hier vorstellen die form später die
nutzung sein wie das
kleinformat was wirst du schauen
was machst du mit der maschine
immer nur gegen sterne gemacht
ich google eine aubergine schneide geben
kann nicht schadet wenn man viel zeit
raubt bewertet jetzt wie gesagt schon
alles hier ansetzen
eine satelliten diskutiert und so dick
ist dafür ein schnitzel hier hier muss
keine peanuts
mustern abgeschmeckt ja und ist jetzt
kein hexenwerk und außergewöhnlich ist
das bisher gemacht habe war mir gefällt
die konsistenz auf jeden fall sehr gut
als ob wir uns also was deftiges wäre
[Musik]
ja ihr habt noch genau 30 minuten hälfte
der zeit wieder dass ich gar nicht weg
ist wo solch eine pannierstraße waren
benutzt kleinen stühlen und lade die
nutzen - wahrscheinlich einfach alles
aus
[Musik]
nach augenmaß komplett
nicht
[Musik]
brauchen ich habe gesagt das war einfach
zu viel butter gestartet
[Musik]
nach iso guckt wieder aubergine
geschnitten wird aber guckt nicht wie
man möchte mails musste nach richtig
arbeiten ist eine mail oder so vor allem
die note ich habe jetzt schon
rückenschmerzen
arbeitet kriegt das ist so ein
quadratmeter kopf
duell ihr habt doch genau 20 minuten
läuft gut aber
ich weiß nicht was das ist die kehrseite
nach dem muster
[Musik]
kochst du immer so für gäste wenn ich
eine gästekarte dann ist das meistens
richtig nämlich katharina oder ordner
passt da kann ich tun ok mit tomate
mozzarella so sind wir geschmack sind
krisen hat letztendlich dass der pilz
dickflüssigen will kann es mir verraten
was du machen möchtest deutsche die
lasagne platte ist mit vor wochen wir
sind aber sehr brüchig jetzt hier
angemeldet sind sind auch die knappen zu
geben mit dieser eingereicht werden ich
war überholte ich gerade keine
angst vor dem ergebnis gekommen ich sag
mal so neun minuten 30 bis die lasagne
in den rufen muss
schichten es ist wirklich wichtig platz
mit dem wir aushalten muss ich ein
bisschen gucken aber das ist auch gut
weil dann kann man also schön
komprimieren und hat so schön bissig
muss sagen beides sieht auf seine art
und weise gut aus ich denke ich
überhaupt nicht wie drei schichten
fünf minuten noch hast du noch mal eine
andere fort ich mache
[Musik]
das ist ja nur form des winters zu wind
und hat
noch nicht genug ist das ist
gar nicht zufrieden weil sie durch diese
ganzen kleinigkeiten konnte es nicht so
machen wie ich mir das gewünscht hätte
aber ich bin mir sicher dass trotzdem
nicht
erste aufgabe ist erledigt werden beide
unsere lasagne zaubers war anders als
erwartet weil die form so winzig ist der
platz zu wenig war aber ich glaube am
ende des tages habe ich eigentlich ganz
ansehen ich bis dahin gezaubert und
setzte aus dem backofen kommt dazu auch
nicht ganz schlecht aussehen da sind
dass ich gar keine erwartungen hatte bin
ich sehr zufrieden also ich hätte nicht
gedacht dass ich das so gut hinbekomme
ich weiß nicht wie es schmeckt am ende
aber es sieht für mich halt aussehen
lassen dass die hauptsache also beide
lasagne sind fertig eric stellte jetzt
in den backofen wir dürfen da nicht mehr
gucken ich würde sagen 20 minuten später
habe sie gut im auge und wir machen dann
noch das schlitzen schnell fertig
[Musik]
es sieht einfach nur köstlich aus
es sind auf jeden fall leichte
unterschiede zu erkennen sage ich mal so
dass sie gut aussah wie
ihr wisst gar nicht wie sehr ich mich
auch diese essen freuen
sie zu gut aus bei
einer übertrumpfen sich
[Musik]
noch mit augen geöffnet seid ihr bereit
wie süß gemacht das ist möglichst viel
wird der fahre seit drüber und in zwei
basilikumblätter höheren drauf aber
ansonsten entweder
zufällig kommen in unsere mitte und
fälle das urteil erstmal was sagst du zu
aufträgt und keiner kriegt habe auch den
ganzen entstehungsprozess gesehen und so
weiter und rein optisch weiter nicht
zehn von zehn aber wenn ich jetzt
entscheiden müsste sich das liebevoll
aber das ansprechen da der vergleich bin
irgendwie das gegenteil so das sieht aus
wie bei 908 909 meine leute gemacht
hatte lässt sich gut schneiden besser
als gedacht wie man so eine schöne klare
probt ich würde sagen dass arte
konkurrenz
style kann oder muss man wirklich sagen
also schätze
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht was ich sagen wollte es
wirklich nicht was ich sagen sollte
textur kraftpaket schon bridge oder die
panade dieses doppelte panieren hat doch
wirklich einen unterschied gemacht genau
so wie es mir vorgestellt alle
erwartungen jetzt schon übertroffen
jetzt eine lasagne die finde ich sie
genauso aus wie man sie ihn sogar
trattoria bekommen zu außen schild
verbrannt leicht so eine perfekte
christen am st
okay was ist natürlich ganz gemüse
schreiben gelassen hier hat alles klein
gemacht und in der soße mit mit
integriert
hier kommt das gemüse dort finden weil
dir schmecken mir die zucchini aubergine
ich möchte mal noch mehr raus schmeckt
auf übelste geschmack ich bin ich
vollkommen zu probieren jetzt kommt er
zu
ich habe mir auch noch eine karte er
hatte
das stets
kranker kommt die krankenkasse ist ja
wirklich keinen kopf darüber dass lara
das so gut weil das würde kraft das uns
erstmal auf essen noch mehr essen auf
und dann kommt das ergebnis ist gleich
deine lasagne war gemüse frischer
apotheken traditioneller sehr sehr
lecker deininger sanierbar mit sahne mit
parmesan in der bischof mit parmesan
hobeln aber sagen wer ist schlauer cola
schmeckt lecker ist auch sehr lecker der
gewinner des ersten offiziellen
kanal ist
dieser titel
gewonnen und schlage beides waren nur 10
von 10 für mich jetzt hier unter diesem
moment aber die das von einer nadel ja
das war das sagt mein tag gemacht note
und komplett also ich bin bei dir ich
würde auch sagen dass da war die
gewinnerin ist so daran gemessen dass
ich seit eineinhalb jahren kopf videos
noch unklar nur typen essen sonst
konnten alle wünschten richtig gut
gemacht und verdienter sieg der versuch
schauen wir zunächst mal gut ich hoffe
dass etwas eingefallen falls hier
kommentiert auch bei darauf ob als
gewinne sind des heutigen tages hat sie
sich das mehr als verdient dann kommt
eric danke an die videoleuchte und
zuletzt dankeschön
[Musik]